so um bad data it exists um I'm going to
talk a little bit about it uh today not
an exhaustive um exhaustive
U exhaustive research on all kinds of
bad data just things I've seen and um
probably you've seen um bit about me I
run logarithm Labs um provide Technical
and strategic U data Consulting Services
uh before starting logarithm um I worked
at Google on the TPU Hardware which is
the machine learning accelerator on
infrastructure and analytics I worked on
um uh fpgs which are programmable
Hardware devices um ayling which is now
part of
AMD um and um and a couple of other
companies but my background before uh
doing data work was um was as a hardware
Hardware
designer uh okay so starting with why
like um why are we talking about bad
data why is it interesting so um what
are the consequences so bad data has
consequences what are some like um if
you present analysis u based on bad data
people will mistrust the analysis um and
and you lose a bit of credibility within
either your org or your exact team
things like that
um um bad data also leads to data
project failures or delays um you make
some assumptions about the data and um
uh when you encounter things which are
not um not what you expect then you end
up with uh with delays it's very hard to
explain these sorts of delays to um to
to various stakeholders within the
organization in in general a bad things
happen when you have bad data so you
know just um just to keep that in mind
um the second thing around is like why
why do we have bad data like where does
it come from um so one one recent Trend
that I've seen uh seen is people are
trying to
um are trying to repurpose Legacy data
to uh address new use cases and there's
a good reason for doing that a lot of
lot of Enterprises specifically have
have have lots of old data and most of
the time it has been used for like
workflows and things like that uh but
people are trying to repurpose them for
like machine learning and and predictive
sort of um
models and so going back to Old Legacy
data that's like one source where the
data might not
um data might not have been collected
like for its intended use and um um the
second is like depending on the
organization is is the data that's
collecting and that you're analyzing is
it is it part of the a primary use case
right like for making recommendations or
or is it part of a peripheral use case
you're collecting data as part of a
workflow but then you're trying to
analyze it to um to make some
predictions about the future um and
human errors obviously if there are um
places where humans are entering data
then you end up with bad data if they
aren't if it isn't
validated um and so the reason I decided
to um to actually make this talk
proposal is um you know if you're
starting a data project or if you're
already part of a data project you
should think about bad data scenarios
and try to improve the improve the odds
of success um you'll you'll hopefully
think um see some gchas that you can um
uh you can avoid but
also
um also also like you communicate better
with the rest rest of the organization
about the quality of data and such um
and if you have a chance to collect data
for whatever use case it is that you're
addressing uh keep in mind that um the
methods that you use to collect data
could could um either make it good data
or bad data um so before we talk about
like bad data and what sorts of things
um they are uh what is the what is good
data and um so there's a definition
well-known definition by hardle wome uh
called tidy data and this is like kind
of how data is organized where you know
every variable is a column every
observation is a row and every type of
organization is a table and and this is
a good way to think think about how to
organize data sets uh and Beyond Beyond
just the formats of how data is stored
like you should think about a well-
defined schema uh data dictionary
defining columns and data structures uh
make sure columns have consistent data
types and U Provence um which basically
means uh try to understand where the
data that you analyzing or using for
Downstream use cases came
from um so I mean another observation is
good data really only exists in
tutorials bad data exists most other
places um and there isn't a clear
definition of what what I mean by bad
data it's kind of messy in different
ways
um in large
Enterprises um depending on what um what
corner of the organization you're um on
uh exess is often used as a database um
it's convenient and easy um and
everybody understands it um but it's
also also manual many processes um many
processes that are captured in Excel or
manual um and they lead to errors um
inconsistent formats um often currencies
date times you'll see big variations in
those sorts of things
um text formats this is again like
across Industries U every domain tends
to have some text formats which are
optimized for human readability because
people are reading those uh reports uh
but they're very hard uh for machines to
parse correctly and then you have to
write all these parsers which end up
with errors um or or or for for
Downstream use cases and they end up
with errors uh units of measurement um
if you work with anything anything which
is like a physical uh physical thing
then um it you you usually will refer to
things like a width thickness or um
distance um time things like that
um um also large organizations languages
and
geographies they um uh you you'll see
like you can't always assume that uh
that the data you're getting is in
English and um for analysis Downstream
you might have to make some uh make some
adjustments um time stamps you know like
not everybody is using the iso uh
formats uh so
local um local dates and times often
introduce errors in very unexpected ways
and we go through some example us we use
um mmdd uh y y y y probably and U you
know Europe in um India for example uses
the date uh for the day first the uh
date month and then the year a manual we
we talked about the manual data errors
and um typos again like if they make
their way through uh it can lead to some
odd uh conclusions that you can draw
from your
data um also uh people often have like
small web applications that they're
using to capture various kinds of data
and if you don't store if you don't
validate data when someone's entering
say at a factory shop floor uh an
operator is entering results of some
experiment and you don't have validation
there you'll end up with weird um things
many of these are captured by modern web
applications but some applications are
Legacy applications and in an Enterprise
space you have to deal with a lot of
these sorts of things
um um there's also a lot of metadata
which just gets captured in names and
you just have to be careful careful
about those cuz names are usually
created by humans and humans are very
very
clever um so we talked about um sort of
all the reasons sources so we talk a bit
about like how Excel CSV variations
again like kind of common use case use
cases
um
um uh so so just um take example of like
a directory like a shared folder or a
directory structure and these are
like um these are kind of some examples
I've seen about how people structure the
data to address some use cases um so
directory names yeah be like um you have
like a base directory within the
directory you'll have a product a and
then you have some test results on it uh
sometimes the directory will have a date
associated with it like um like that um
and same for product a you have uh the
test results um uh sometimes these dates
won't actually have a date they'll have
a word like latest um which also has the
latest test results as of today right so
um uh this is also kind of meant for
humans to consume if you're parsing um
you know if you're parsing you have to
write some code to make sure latest is
tagged the right way when latest gets
moved to a new date you have to D
duplicate your data things like that
um uh then then there will be clever
users who will go in there make some
modifications to the data they don't
want to touch the original and uh
they'll rename it to something with
their name on
it um now you don't really know whether
uh now you don't really know like um
whether uh whether I should pick this
modified modified data is this the real
data or is this latest the real data I
don't know
um um obsolete you know you made some
changes it's been pushed somewhere and
you say okay this data is now obsolete
but I don't really want to delete it and
so you'll end up with that um capturing
hierarchy so let's say you have product
a which uses multiple components um
people will create a data structure
essentially um by nested directories and
U um you know and you kind kind of end
up the same but there's an implicit um
there's an implicit hierarchy of how you
what are the components within this
product and that is captured within the
directory tree name so uh so like the
point of all this is like you don't know
like how these things are getting used
so when you're pulling data in from like
a fil like uh structure make sure you're
always capturing the name the file name
the directory name things like that so U
so you can de um so you can de identify
like the data where the data came from
later and also create additional
metadata uh which is captured here um
how exactly to do that that depends on
the
situation
um now this is another example which is
uh which is common fairly common it's
easy to handle but it's fairly common uh
when you're first reading a large you
know large repository of files which are
in some text or Excel Excel formats uh
this this is an example where just the
headers in one of the files is missing
you're reading like you know 1,000 files
one of the files is missing a header and
then when you take you know one data
frame and you concatenate it with
another data frame you you end up with
this
um um these columns which are obviously
not the right columns uh here U again
this is just a madeup example where you
should you should have batch uh test
name result and the uh and the unit of
the result in um in one file those are
the four columns you should expect
um but you know you did a PD read CSV
and uh it didn't have a header and um
and so you ended up with something like
this
um again like a a trick here is like as
you're parsing files um as you're paring
files in you can keep checking and then
sort of stall otherwise some of these
reading large uh number of files can
also uh take a long time especially if
you're accessing files over a
network um typos in column names this
again is a common scenario um cuz
somebody edited a file like um edited a
file and introduced a space so what you
see here is again like you're reading a
bunch of files and you see some extra
columns that you don't um don't expect
and
um like for the most part like you open
the file up it also looks looks to be
the same and um um you obviously have
like a space at the end here there could
be other typos like that but these are
pretty high hard to
visually visually inspect and
catch values um again similar things
like a slight variations uh here it's
not the column name but like the test
name is is a categorical variable if you
think about um there are only certain
kinds of desks now you're trying to do a
group by um have to find the maximum you
know which of these batches had the
maximum strength um in the measurement
or or thickness in the measurement uh
you end you end up with seeing like two
things in your group by Aggregate and
that's obviously not uh correct and if
you present the data out um then you're
obviously presenting incorrect data if
you're um if you're not careful about
this this is easy to see because you
only have four categorical uh or you
only have three categorical variables
and you know that there should be a
fourth but you should do things like
strip spaces and um run value counts or
find the unique values in a particular
column to make sure that um that you
don't have these typos which cause
Downstream
problems units is another thing we saw
units um was one of the columns we
weren't making any use of it uh but
imagine like there are um
uh there are other values you're adding
to the table um something something like
a visual inspection which is uh which
either says this product is acceptable
like the Finish quality the product is
acceptable or not acceptable and somehow
that this gets into the same column that
has numeric values in it and um you know
and of course like numbers we know how
to handle Max Min things um when you
have words in them you know again here
you're trying to do a group by an
aggregate of the Max and Min uh the
order of what is good and bad like um
that that might not uh so there's
there's like an order 012 that you
implicitly have in mind which might not
match alphabetical order and again like
issues with like capital letters or
small letters you could end up with with
bad things
um uh another example again like from a
real life um example uh here is um
you're doing some measurements out of a
factory or an instrument or something
like that um you're doing batches you
got a new instrument where um where say
the instrument is able to measure things
more accurately but um but they changed
the unit in which they report the
measurements so you know here let's say
you you went from millimeter thickness
to micrometer thickness cuz your
instruments now are more precise uh but
your data sets have haven't taken care
of it you didn't you didn't use unit um
you you didn't use unit in any of your
calculations when you're doing group
bues and things like that and you didn't
generate a new just just a pure form
um um a number uh taking units into
account so you'll obviously end up with
something which is like a thousand times
more uh more than what you had uh
similar things like if you have like
miles and kilometers or meters and um um
you know meters and feet things like
those could get pretty
dicey uh then you know I have this
category of human Ingenuity which is
which is really people trying to hack
unvalidated data sources so again this
is um this is an example where like
Legacy application was used to collect
data and U everything generally
typically is nicely structured
but uh but for a bunch of observations
there there were two observations
written into one row and this obviously
is not not right and if you aren't aware
of that then you'll either miss miss it
or when you're trying to join the batch
number from One data set to another data
set then you'll end up with some um
either missing values or something like
that so so something to be careful about
again like you can add assertions you
run some basic checks to make sure
there's uh there's only one value it
follows a certain format there's many
ways in which you can validate it but
part of uh part of um part of it is to
figure out how did this bad data make
its way into my database um and and
often it's like someone uh when they
coded it up the application just works
when they coded it up it wasn't it
didn't have any error U error checking
at the data capture
Point um languages I talked about this a
little bit earlier um when you have
multinational sites people entering data
free form um there's some guidelines and
if those guidelines aren't double
checked then um it you end up with
problems so again like if we look at um
from this again like from a real life um
example uh multinational site all of
them working on similar things and you
end up with different um different words
to describe the same thing um I me in
this case like Italian German and I
think that's Korean um
um what you what you really have here is
you have three ordered categories but
you have 12 values and so somehow you
need to map one to the other so just be
careful of that like if if you are
treating uh for example uh these things
as ground truth data then you want to
fix the data um you know into the number
of ordered ordered categories that you
have
so uh dates and months again
multinational Prett um sites pretty um
pretty annoying when you when you run
into this um so just to give you an
example of like these are silent errors
that you wouldn't wouldn't see and often
you have to use other mechanisms to
disambiguate which data set came from uh
came from where so uh so take this data
set all of these dates are supposed to
be in March so uh the top data at here
uh comes
from um us from the US presumably and
then the uh second data set comes from
um you know Europe or
India so you see here that all of these
are in March but when you take um take
this data set concatenate it and do a PD
uh two date time a conversion you end up
with these two just these two values
which end up in May and December but all
the other values they stay um uh they
stay you you see a warning like that and
if you see a warning like that it
doesn't mean that um other um other
roles in your data set were converted
correctly you so in this case you only
have three warnings but uh for three
rows U but um but there are two other
rows where you end up with incorrect um
data uh incorrect dates so yeah just be
mindful
careful
um um so if you have messy data you
still have to deal with it you know um
how do you deal with it there are
certain certain techniques
um so certain techniques there isn't
like one Holy Grail but like uh I always
try to understand how the data was
generated and this means asking
questions to various people different
they could belong to different teams
different parts of the organization but
once you understand how the data was
generated you're just more more aware of
what are the things you need to watch
out for um in term terms of bad data um
if you can uh work with those teams to
minimize Source um the sources of Errors
um when it's at the point of capture
then it's probably a good time um have a
good time and often this means like if
if it's in Excel you have templates and
the templates have validations and
things like that and people generally
don't mess with those uh if you have web
applications then you um then you have
the assumptions about the data bu into
your validation uh so that people aren't
able to enter bad data in there um uh
but what do you do like when you have
messy data and you have to go through a
bunch of uh Transformations um document
all the assumptions about the data I
mean often times it means like whether
if you have a notebook don't just write
the notebook if you made some
assumptions uh somewhere uh then just
write a quick assertion so that the uh
so that you either get get like a log
something out in the logs or or
or
um you know the notebook execution fails
so that you can go go back and look and
you don't keep pushing that data out
into some other third third system
um um like if you're doing workflow
steps like taking one you know automate
and make sure they're reproducible these
are all pretty uh pretty standard
practices um if you're using a big you
know like a framework like you know meta
flow or airflow or something uh like
that that's fine but if you aren't and
you're just running notebooks um hitting
run all then try to see if you can use U
make files things like that um use good
naming conventions yourself um and um
think about the debug ability of the
data so what I mean by that is like a
debugging code is like different process
than debugging data and um if you're
making some assumption you know write
out um into into some logs of files um
like aggregations which you might not
need um if you have expectations that
there should only be five five
categorical variables in this column um
write an assertion so that if something
comes comes down that you trap it catch
it and uh you fix it at at the source
and these are some tools that I um I
typically use when I um either am
developing developing some
um some new data engineering pipelines
and I'm seeing a data set for a first
time for the first time or I'm trying to
ingest data that I haven't seen before
or it's a new data set i'm unfamiliar
with um um these are some things I use
um um like again like um there are many
many many data tools available um some
of the simpler ones are actually quite
quite effective uh sqlite is one of them
it it's really easy to use and and um
specifically I mean in the case of there
are many many users of sqlite I just
mean like for the case of data
transformation you you might have your
data sitting on snowflake or
AWS or you know or a shared Drive fairly
easy to use SQL light to pull that data
in capture it on a local file um it
comes included with python the zero
setup uh it's a single file if you've
never used it you should try it most
people have probably used it here um but
if you haven't you should try it um it's
a single file captures multiple files
data sets and you can just email it to
somebody or uh share the data with
somebody if you're collaborating with
them very very easy to use
um um so the way I kind of uh use it for
data transformation is like it's because
it's quick and it's local U I might pull
some data in into raw format into a SQL
light database and then start making
Transformations from there and this
might not be the entire data set but
just kind of like a subsample of uh
subsample example of data that um you
know or even even like if it isn't a
huge huge data set sqlite can handle
large files um it's just local it's very
fast um and I can stage transformation I
can almost use it as a lightweight data
versioning uh versioning Tool uh either
at the file level or at the table level
as I'm making transformation so it's
quite quite useful for that um and using
it is fairly simple uh if you use
notebooks and pandas it's um you know
you just write try to SQL any and and
you name a table name here and that
table name gets
generated uh now another tool which I
use uh this is not a tool I have written
this is a tool from Simon Willison who
is a very um active blogger his blog is
amazing and the data set um the tool
called data set is also pretty amazing
this is picked up from um from just the
first page documentation of U of the
tool that he has done um for exploring
data data of any shape size U you know
explore it publish it so the way it
works is you um I'm not sure if anybody
has seen this or heard of this uh it
works only with SQL light databases as
far as I know so it doesn't connect to
postgress or snowflake or anything like
that but you uh and there's a pretty
nice ecosystem around this um Baseline
data set um tool um it's open source
um um so after installing it you just
pass it to sqlite databases which are
just files and
um you you get a web interface which has
all the tables and the and the files um
uh so as you're making Transformations
for example it's you know I start with
some baseline make some Transformations
uh create a merged file then I can uh um
I can easily explore the data with uh
three three primary things filter facet
and sort those are those are ways to
just see okay did my transformation work
how many different categories did I end
up with before and after the
Transformations um things like that um
if you're looking for particular values
sort you don't have to go be in the
notebook and kind of um uh keep running
Panda commands essentially as you're
making these changes over and over again
so you make the transformmission you
write it out and you hit reload and then
you can see what you used to see before
um you know also support SQL so if there
are some queries that you're constantly
running after making the Transformations
again you just override the table uh hit
refresh and you you get back the new
data and so the process of
iteration um on a new data set or um
gets fairly
easy
um so yeah I mean there were a bunch of
examples here and like what are some key
takeaways from this like bad data exists
in the real um world um a spending
analysis time looking at science of bad
data is not time badly spent like this
is time that is important for Downstream
it's very hard to explain why this is
time well spent um but if you're working
in an organization you should make an
effort to uh to essentially say okay you
know before we start building these
models or these dashboards or these
predictions we need to make sure that
we're doing it on data which is good and
that is how um you'll build uh
credibility as well as accuracy So
within the organization um so just build
good habits around this
um um yeah and you know if you're
working with Messy data sets then um
everybody has their own sort of workflow
you should develop some own some good
habits uh around that so um so you can
iterate through through new data sets
very
quickly um learning how data was
generated this was very very instructive
for me as I went went and talked to
various people so talking talking to
people is actually good like you
shouldn't just stare at the scen screen
go talk to some people it's very um
helpful
um now bad data in your databases is
also a signal that there's something in
your organization that needs to improve
so there's always uh always
opportunities to to help your
organization uh even while dealing with
bad data set ask questions about um you
know can we do anything to improve the
efficiency can we introduce automation
anywhere um you learn a lot more
business context around um around your
team your group
um um and your company and hopefully
that'll do good things for your career
uh that's all I have to say if um there
are questions happy to
[Music]
answer
how often do you hear oh just this is JN
just let the AI take care of this uh
yeah so uh that's a good question many
many projects I start many projects I
start out with uh typically at the exact
level um they want to you know people
want to use AI like there's a lot of
things that are happening with uh Ai and
people want to use use these modern um
things
um um so yeah part of my job is just
explaining that um you need good data to
train your models um you you you can't
just throw like a directory full of
Excel files at tensor flow you know it's
not going to work so how do you go about
collecting the data so that you even
have a um even have a sh at um running
running a linear regression model for
example
yeah yeah what's your best answer for
extracting data from a PDF file or a
bunch of PDF
files uh yeah so um PDF files are really
um
um yeah so like where I have dealt with
PDF files I've generally Ed like an API
from Amazon like textt trct or um you
know document something from um from
Google usually companies have uh
companies have that um the outputs you
get from that are really low level you
can extract tables and things like
tables and things like that from within
PDF files um but the lowlevel output
typically tends to be hears a word or
here's a line and here's the location
and you have to do something with it uh
presumably some newer
um um yeah I've heard that there are
some newer newer products which handle
that uh but if there are specific things
that I'm looking for in a PDF uh for for
example extracting just the words and
searching so like at a client for
example they wanted to see whether the
word you know whe whether uh like a
cosmetic was um tested on animals right
so and lot of um lot of the files were
sitting in PDF files so even just just a
text and uh just doing a text search on
those works okay but there's yeah PDFs
are pretty to deal with no no good
answer use apis I suppose yeah do you
have a good answer no does anybody have
a good
answer um not really but a Shameless
plug or plea um whatever I was doing
Pike PDF seemed better than and mine
couldn't be calling out to a web service
I had to be running on the machine Pike
PDF seemed to be the least bad of the
bunch um it's available in cond for
Linux or Mac if you want it on Windows
it's in PIP it's still not in cond if
anyone actually use candy with open
source please put it in cond for Windows
please please um thank you yeah so um so
there are like other kinds of PDF
parsers too where if the text in the PDF
is actually text that you can select
like in a browser or you know then it
works but often PDFs tend also to be
images and um some of you know like you
still need the OCR OCR on the PDF which
is pretty annoying
yeah yeah um I just feel like this whole
presentation Su been looking over my
shoulder for the last 10 years of my
career so thank you um um you'd think
it's 2023 we figured out Unicode by now
but I'm sure you've seen cases where
non-latin characters did funny things
yeah yeah I went through an example um
here um we have where it's different
translations but also where it's yes
yeah yeah like um at least here it's
actually rendering right because you can
also have where it's like slow smiley
because it doesn't know that that's a
different Lang but it it thinks that's
Latin one yeah uh yeah yeah um but yeah
that
um yeah that not much to do about that
yeah with Python 3 I think handles all
this stuff fairly
well thank
[Applause]
you